[Musique]
je sais pas ce que c'est un peu le genre
ils peuvent faire décoller une carrière
faire d'un inconnu une star tout ça en
échange de 10 % du cachet je parle des
agents de comédiens un métier de l'ombre
popularisé avec la série télévisée 10%
déjà en 1967
deux jeunes agents alors appelé
imprésario répondait aux questions d'un
journaliste
comme ce sont des inconnus absolument il
faut les imposer dans les productions et
ça c'est très difficile les agents sont
comme des chefs d'orchestre de l'ombre
homme ou femme de confiance
il organise des rencontres entretiennent
leur relation avec des producteurs ou
des metteurs en scène et tente de placer
leurs protégés
alors pour les jeunes artistes trouver
un bon agent est primordial pour se
lancer
vous sentez guetté par les après
j'arrive dans les années 80 beaucoup de
jeunes comédiens tentent de se lancer et
l'agent peut parfois se montrer disons
oppressant faites moi plaisir en me
disant voilà on va voir les metteurs en
scène comme ça contre ces jolis seins
ils existent ils sont l'art est une
vraie femme
enfin bref une fois que le jeune premier
et repérer l'agent est toujours présent
son rôle éviter les faux pas les navets
comme l'expliqué georges baume agents
d'alain delon romy schneider ou encore
simone signoret en 1981
d'une façon générale les comédiens ne
savent pas y compris ceux qui sont
intelligents qui ne sont pas forcément
la majorité ça n'arrête pas avec le
talent elles ne savent pas toujours ce
qui leur convient le mieux et les choix
qu'ils font l'agent doit aussi et
surtout avoir des connaissances de droit
afin de négocier au mieux les contrats
des acteurs car c'est bien sur ces
contrats que l'agent se rémunère
dallaire gens issus actes s'ils
voulaient comme comme quand ça marche
bien pour un acteur ça marche bien pour
l'argent
quand ça marche mal par l'acteur ça
marche aussi mal pour le prochain
[Musique]